do you think it's possible for somebody
shooting arrow another person with a
sword to chop it in half oh if you do it
I'd be more than impressed
I love archery
I love swords I love action movies now
I've seen in action movies people arrow
flying at them sword cut see you're out
in the air
I'm wondering is that possible can you
actually do that how hard is it to do in
my life of making action films sometimes
I have to try out these impossible
things and see just how hard they really
are so I know if it's cool to put it in
my scene
since we're gonna try to do today
chopping an arrow out of the air with a
sword busy just working what's up I need
somebody to shoot an arrow at me so I
can chop it out of there with a sword
you want me to shoot at you well you
decide me well with depending on the
arrow I mean I could make it a safe
arrow would would wears what is this for
uh personal discovery practice it's her
practice I'm practicing Jake you're
doing this as an experiment do you think
that this can be done remember how long
it took us to catch that Nerf dart for
the chopstick I mean remember who caught
the nerf start with the chopstick
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I think it could be done I mean
here's the thing we won't know until we
try I got a sword
I got an arrow I got a bow the only
thing I don't have is a friend who's
gonna help me out will you be my friend
I'll be your friend all right all right
all right well I'm gonna give anything
together you owe me meet me out there in
like 20 minutes
sure okay well I guess I better go get
ready myself I gotta stretch before we
do real or else we're gonna start with
something just a little bit safer so
we're gonna sorry this artery attack
though our tree attack arrow which is
basically basically just a large barrel
no sleeping chop this you can hit this
with a sword before its target etc well
upgrade it to the real deal it's a very
difficult task
I mean arrows fly fast I feel like
reaction time has to be pretty on point
well it's probably possible I don't
think it's gonna be easily achieved by
anybody in the studio here do you think
an ego can chop up the arrow with the
sword if it's on the table arrows going
sideways and you're going show your son
you're talking to a man who high-fived
an arrow out of the air with another
person
I think it's possible if we could do it
with our hands we can do it with this
sword so this is my katana Sam got this
for me for my birthday it's a very nice
katana not one of those mall ninjas
pieces part of my French very sharp it's
a little stain from citric acid because
we were chopping fruit with it back in
the day I haven't taken the time to buff
it out because honestly I like it what
my possessions get character that tells
a story brings back memories
I'd never sharpened this sword still
good though so this should be able to
handle an arrow also good handle your
legs if you're not careful so either be
safe
here's the thing about Nico and whenever
he says 20 meet me out there and like
really and Nico terms it really means 40
so when you have a friend like that you
off that time to kill I'm playing rage
shadow legends that's right it's the
sponsor of today's video it's one of the
best RPG mobile games out there got
awesome graphics
it's got great little story line you're
into medieval fantasy stories it's got
huge boss fights it's got an awesome
group of champions that you can collect
and customize yourself it has physical
prizes that you can win in tournaments
and get them shipped directly to your
door did I also mention that it's
free-to-play just download it right now
the links in the description and if you
guys sign up now you'll get 50,000
silver included a free epic champion and
you'll be entered into a special
tournament automatically where we have a
select group of champions that we've
customized to play against so you could
get to play against us in that
tournament so anyway you guys want to
check it out links in the description me
go
three dude yeah check out this gimbal
got 60 mil lens on this thing I'm
getting some sweet shots Brandon do you
think it's possible for somebody's
shooting arrow another person with a
sword to chop it in half
yes it is absolutely possible but you
have to be swinging and being going like
through the motion of your swing before
the arrows even released from the bow I
mean I don't know any statistics on this
sort of thing I just say it's very very
hard if you do it I'd be more than
impressed my face gets shot with an
arrow he's waiting for you yeah uh looks
like you're ready you know how like
those gangsters wear that the bandana is
like below their eyebrows og gangster
what's up man I'd like that enthusiasm
I'd expect nothing less from Jake than
what I have right now I can start
chopping if you want to start slinging
there's my friend standing here unaware
that it's curvy Archer is about to take
a shot I'm gonna defend my friend I just
deflected oh it's no good I need to chop
the arrow in half so the two pieces go
around them all right all right first
shot I cannot wait to kill that priest
didn't get all that gold
[Music]
loose
oh I skimmed it just a little bit
you took the fletching off but that's
not gonna save your friend no it didn't
save my friend but I will right now the
same thing we're just making it thinner
at the top I need a new arrow doing
enough distance here that's a thing
maybe Dijkstra back
but I think you need to use more brute
downward strength I could do it
oh no way trying to hit the shaft of an
arrows at twice by that's impossible
I bet you I can do it yelling you know
yeah no good man I even ate dirt with
that one
took a knock off again tried to bury the
tip and dirt the sharpest sword you
could cut someone's head off with this
luckily we have a guillotine subscribe
just don't don't bury in the dirt
apparently Nico barely barely touched it
don't you got to bury the dirt you
buried it once I get one okay
maybe try hitting the arrow this time
it's funny guy bury this in the dirt
becoming the Undertaker
I hit it I hit it dead center okay yeah
the arrow doesn't break at all keeps
going that's not good
the whole point this is a sieve is even
possible or realistic so far it looks
like it's impossible to slice an arrow
in half so I'm gonna test to see if wood
works any better because right now the
arrows just keep bouncing off the blade
yeah the archery tech girls are made of
fiberglass and we're wondering if that
thing and harder to chop them I think
there's enough
it's ding leave a mark well I'm gonna
try to chop it the same way as before I
mean I'm basically doing this like
Jake's look a lot trusted me both as a
friend and as a fellow scientist because
we're using a wooden arrow here in the
movies all those arrows are made out of
wood I have a regular steel sword here
this should work if I've seen enough
movies to tell me the truth about life
Jake I hope I don't hit you if I do I
hope the cameras are rolling if you're
not subscribed I think Jake deserves a
subscription for this and we'll get to
it
okay it's faster
he's definitely faster I'll be able to
hit it I just gotta anticipate it a
little bit more okay just like they do
in real life we can forgive the fact
that like it's very unlikely as long as
it's possible under time circumstances
there's a possibility that it could
happen in a real battle
[Music]
oh crap man right in the middle leaving
this this you could stab another guy
okay none of Adobe did we actually save
the Manas the the priest though by now
let's see the thing I am so impressed
- Jake's bouncing he's getting ready
boom oh we did not say the friends
totally took an arrow is a priest died
that was beautiful wow that was so clean
though look at this I Lejeune we didn't
think you're gonna get this I didn't
either
you can do it so now they gonna source
on hidden arrow he can chop it in half
and theoretically if his friends gonna
be a little further away he would save
his life when you see it in a film we
know that it's possible this is such a
clean cut it smells like fresh-cut wood
smell that serious crime in the corridor
crew cool stuff coming out all the time
come along with us on our adventure as
we do crazy stuff for our art and crafts
so there's cool experiments because
that's who we are still taken just
absolutely taken by this next week we
chop things with a guillotine that's
right